this was the largest audience to ever  witness an inauguration period  alternative facts there are pictures now  which appear to show  boxes and boxes of sudafed and upper  he's going to eliminate overtime for  hundreds of thousands of postal workers  which could delay mail services and of  course prevent the delivery of the  ballot i am proud to shut down the  government for border security because  the people of this country don't want  criminals and people that have lots of  problems in fact i'll get that little  piece of dandruff for  them it'll be we have to make him  perfect he is perfect i think that would  qualify as not smart but genius and a  trump paid a total  of 750 in federal income taxes the year  that he won the presidency